the European Union is a unique and
exceptional community of countries we
are very grateful that we are treated
with our pavilion with the exhibition
the opening of this pavilion today and
this ceremony here that we are treated
on equal footing with all the other
participants because the European Union
is a unique and exceptional community
one day after the 70th anniversary a
German in Italy is addressing a
multinational assembly in a World
Exhibition this is a good signal for all
of us you have to look for a better
future not only for us in Europe also
taking an account that we are living in
a world village we are affected by
whatever happens in another part of the
world and your country Italy especially
is affected by the migration problems
caused by civil wars caused by hunger
caused by economic depression and one of
the biggest reasons for people to leave
from their region is hunger should
provide food security health and water
provide this are decisive elements for
peace in the world